hat es korrekt getrennt in den final
fight the match 0 des wird das was wird
das was wird das was für services kids
und herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen
folge minecraft heute spielen wir
und mir kommt irgendwie vor als wenn man
ev ein bisschen manipuliert worden
na wer hat immer mehr verfahren gespielt
erwartet wer war es keine ahnung war ich
vielleicht lockt schon ich bin es immer
noch leute heute möchte ich euch gerne
mal zeigen wie man seine kopfhörer
richtig ins ohr steckt wobei das kann
ich nicht mehr selbst nicht möchte ich
was erzählen und zwar pro a wieder hart
am rating mit diesem parcours
der ist nämlich alles andere als sie
wieder da ist es normal aber ich mich
nicht beschweren haben ja gepackt first
try nice ich will euch hat ein bisschen
was erzählen über das was bevorsteht und
zwar das burger battle und die damit
verbundenen sachen ich will jetzt nicht
sagen konsequenzen weil das so negativ
belastet ist für mich und max und zwar
habe ich euch das vielleicht schon mal
auf twitter gesagt ich glaube noch nicht
in dem video also ich sags euch jetzt
mal so der erste preis einfach mal ganz
direkt gesprochen
fürs burger battle ist eine reise in die
usa
für zwei personen das wurde auch glaube
ich von mcdonald's so offen kommuniziert
deswegen kann ich auch hier sagen und
diese reise würde ich dann mit den
marken antreten weil der mich immer
fleißig unterstützt hat bei diesem
burger battle und der sieg sicher auch
zu großen teilen auch max gehört einfach
aufgrund seiner unterstützung
und ja ich weiß noch nicht wann dieser
trip stattfinden wird aber es geht dann
falls wir das schaffen und den ersten
platz holen können
nach amerika für mich im markt also zwei
personen vielleicht so was so eine art
westcoast trip oder es kostet oder so
ich habe keine ahnung aber auf jeden
fall finde ich das so so cool ich war
noch nie einen starten
und hier richtig brocken immer das mal
anzuschauen weil ich glaube dass ist
schon interessant ist sicher witzig mal
kurz mal hier
die champ hatte anziehen und jetzt bei
uns man hierüber okay das ist das ding
hier könnte man die kommentare schreiben
diesmal in den usa und wenn ja wo und
wie hat euch
die vereinigten staaten sind einfach die
kann man schlecht beschreiben also kann
man kann schlecht sagen vereinigten
staaten sind so die usa sind so weil die
einfach allein territorial also von der
von der fläche des landes her so
ausgedehnt sind es steckt ja alles ist
im track von seattle im norden das
wahrscheinlich eher kalt und regnerisch
ist bis zu kalifornien dem westen
einfach auch so viele nicht nur zeit
sondern auch so viele klimazonen oder
sagt man klima thema glaube ich ne das
ist einfach dabei kann es gar nicht in
einem wort beschreiben was wir auf jeden
fall so cool wenn wir dahin könnten das
wert ist ja echt auch das ein traum von
mir
ich wollte schon immer auf meinen die
staaten das ist lustig in diesem in
diesem bett kommen eigentlich recht
viele träume wahr ich wollte jetzt
einfach dreams come true auf deutsch
übersetzen das geht natürlich nicht dann
geschehen bei der leute muss man jetzt
so lange wenig oder kann man das
schaffen
neu geht sogar aber jetzt die kiste
nicht oben leute wäre ich so cool er
schön sehr schön so aber das heißt ach
ja ich erstmal unter welchen bedingungen
das sind klappen könnte und zwar müssten
wir dafür jetzt nicht nur das halbfinale
das jetzt beginnt also nicht jetzt
sondern am 16 ich lade das video hier am
15 hoch oder sechzehnter ist dann
logischerweise morgen oh ich bin runter
gefallen
das heißt aber dass hier oben die kiste
irgendwo ist weil da hab ich keine kiste
gesehen schade es war ganz gut georgina
wussten die kiste muss man der fläche
unter vollständiger die kiste ist adobes
davids man wo es sie die kunden neu nein
okay es ist einfach nicht ich mache
jetzt einfach mal den parcours und
hoffte einfach die nächste kiste oder
auch nicht lol alter meine ich bin
einfach zombie jesus what the [ __ ]
ja aber ich möchte auch endlich was
erzählen uns was wir wollen thema stehen
geblieben
wie läuft das jetzt also wir sind jetzt
im halbfinale wir sind unter den mord
unter den besten vier bürgern und was
jetzt stattfindet ist das halbfinale
das läuft vom verzicht auf die bürger
sind vom 16 07
bis zum 12 8 in den läden und ich nehme
an dass er auch genauso lange das online
voting läuft und damit dass mit der
usa-reise und so einer wie doc serie
klappen kann müssen wir natürlich alle
ist als aller erstes mal das halbfinale
gewinnen dann kommt das finale
wenn wir das finale gewonnen haben dann
können wir das staaten das mich kurz
konzentrieren soll jetzt hier sehr schön
kurz durchatmen
ja das jetzt das halbfinale treten wir
gegen kiel an
mit einem weiteren schalke 04 burger des
chili irgendwas chili magen vergiftung
aber so heißt die lebensmittelvergiftung
04 ist der glaube ich der bürger
er meint der essen seite ist es schon
besser muss man schon sagen
also mir persönlich schmeckt er
verbesserte antrat für meinen geschmack
viel zu viel soße darauf dass viel zu
süß von bereich finden bürger muss
herzhaft sein und der switching es hat
wirklich suite also sollte eine sweet
sweet sweet sweet land irgendwo ein
bisschen chili und ganz entfernt noch
ein bisschen schicken heißen
gallern aber ganz entfernt ein bisschen
schicken hinten so kann man das hier
schaffen sieht ganz gut aus
ja das ist jetzt das halbfinale also ich
glaube das online voting läuft bis zum
12 8 ab dem 16 und da werden die stimmen
gezählt das heißt man sieht immer wie
viel prozent der gesamtstimmen die
jeweiligen konkurrenten haben dann
stehen zb hoffentlich so es keine ahnung
70 prozent und hessen sind es 70 prozent
und der andere wagen an dem 30 prozent
also um eine vision und der link den
werde ich euch natürlich mitteilen ich
werde morgen auch extra nochmal
definitiv ein video machen und auch
danach ein paar infos videos wie er mich
da unterstützen können weil mir das echt
schon am herzen liegt das wetter das ist
einfach ist es wirklich ein traum also
dass es ist kein käse und ich lege mir
das auch nicht so zurecht dass jetzt
gerade dieses event irgend
die so viel so viele meiner träume
irgendwie berührt das ist einfach echt
so also einmal die sonne also ein
eigenen bürger machen fand ich finde ich
voll cool und so eine amerikareise davon
träume ich alte recht auch schon
wirklich lange das ist kein käse das ist
mir wirklich wichtig ihr wisst ja wenn
ich wenn ich etwas sage dann ist es in
der regel auch die wahrheit
das heißt in der regel ich bin jetzt
kein youtuber der dann ist es eigentlich
immer die wahrheit jetzt kein youtuber
der seine zuschauer groß anlügt im
gegenteil also dass mir wirklich wichtig
dass wenn ich wirklich cool und deswegen
hoffe ich dass wir das reißen können ich
denke max wird da auch noch mal fleißig
unterstützen mit vielen videos jetzt
natürlich auch weil er selbst davon
profitieren kann weil er dann auf den
eventuellen der dieb in die vereinigten
staaten mit kann so kann man das hier
mal so weit kommen wir raus nicken alles
klar
nice kurz konzentrieren
ich werde euch auf jeden fall auf morgen
noch mal ein video produzieren mit allen
infos wie er mich da unterstützen könnt
so jetzt hier first 38 man jetzt okay
meine taktik ist normalerweise dass ich
hier fast durchlaufe also einfach durch
und dann der oben kurz absicherer unter
zurücklaufen wenn das hier das ziel ist
geht es natürlich nicht sagt trotzdem
schon mal jiji
wir können jetzt noch kurz hier
theoretisch müsste ich jetzt natürlich
liegestütze machen aber jetzt haben die
diabetes keiner verleihung das budget
das heißt ich dafür ball aufgehalten
ansonsten wie der bürger ist auch in der
lena sie könnte dann auch probieren zu
speziellen jetzt kämpfen wir erleben
hier noch mal wo ich wollte irgendwie
auf die range zwischen aber ich habe
einfach keine angel genoni okay der
gegners unterirdisch da kommen jetzt
vielleicht nicht hin
es sei denn wir gehen hier runter oder
vorne boxen sich auch drei das sagen
hallo wie zum beispiel diesen crash hier
der wirklich traumhaft das equipment hat
hatte eigentlich irgendeinen gesammelt
doch nicht okay ein guter witz
jetzt wieder einzupacken sehr schön wow
nein nein nein ich will das hier wo man
ich bin heute irgendwie voll voll neben
der spur ich weiß nicht was los ist ob
ich die hydrierung oder so aber
irgendwie ist pvp heute nicht so nicht
so drin bei mir ich habe irgendwie das
gefühl sehr schöner kommen noch dran
wunderbar kommt enke ja der gleich sehe
ich doch kommen und es dauert aber noch
eine rolle
was ist das guckt euch das an wann ich
bin teilweise in den kisten drin ja da
die wirklich keine einzige aufgesammelt
leute da kommt ihr nicht egal richtiger
kilfitt alter die fliegen alle raus na
es jetzt geht es nur noch gegen german
place xx alle analysen jetzt schon
dauern und wie gesagt für dieses
statement gerne mit 0 kills beenden ok
kills also ich hab ich schon mal nicht
denn ich hab ja schon ein paar 06 also
null tode meine ich natürlich so und da
vorne ist
hoffen wir mal dass du mich nicht töten
kann dann hatten wir vor gott rüstung
und hätte schon gedacht dass wir so
einer der die ganze weg läuft mit einer
spam okay den ersten teil haben wir
damit schon mal vielleicht können jetzt
auch die anderen beiden machen ohne
leben zu verlieren
er sieht sich kommen das wird der zweite
save herself und er ist noch mal da
nevzat wir geben jetzt eine chance geben
zu wollen nicht aber so raus werfen
spielen fair trade kurz wie man
hinterher nicht dass er dann an expert
weg läuft ok rektor ich wie früher
herzen mit der verloren habe ich einen
hit zwei zweieinhalb die hat jetzt
wieder drin würde ich sagen okay ort
jetzt gibt es hier so was aber man kann
auch hier hinten hoch glaube ich
wie ist die sache er kann man so er hat
es getan
jetzt geht's in den final fight the
management 0 des wird das was wird das
was wird das was wir dass jacqueline
alter wunderschön 0 tode zinke ist das
ist gut
die gefällt mir gefällt mir und wir
haben sogar noch gefällig eigentlich
richtig coole runde es wenn sich auch
gefallen hat dass eine downline wir
sehen uns wieder frei macht's gut und
bis morgen mit dem nächsten info video
und schauen sich charles knie